[Music]
former afghan president ashraf ghani and
his family who fled afghanistan before
the fall of kabul have now turned up in
the united arab emirates this comes as
thousands of his countrymen and women
along with u.s citizens are also trying
to evacuate the country natalie brand
reports from the white house
the u.s is rushing to increase the
number of people it can evacuate from
afghanistan ahead of the august 31st
withdrawal deadline we predict that our
best effort could look like 5 000 to 9
000 passengers departing per day but
there are reports of chaos outside the
kabul airport with a nato official
telling reuters there is a stampede at
one of the gates and the taliban is
reportedly blocking afghan citizens from
leaving we have received reports
of people being turned away or pushed
back or even beaten we are taking that
up in a
channel with the taliban to try to
resolve those issues
in the eastern city of jalalabad a
health official says at least one person
is dead after taliban soldiers fired
into a crowd protesting against the new
government national intelligence
analysts say there is also concern about
heightened terrorist threats especially
around the 20th anniversary of 9 11.
anybody in the intelligence business
right now here in the united states who
doesn't understand we're in a heightened
threat position
is in reading the analysis the taliban
held its first press conference tuesday
claiming it will respect women's rights
the u.s joined 46 other countries in a
statement saying we are deeply worried
about afghan women and girls their
rights to education work and freedom of
movement we have to see what they do
we hear what they're saying
but it is their actions that really will
define how they address these issues
moving forward
the u.n says it will remain on the
ground in afghanistan to support
programs for women and girls natalie
brandt cbs news the white house